I'd like to address something that I
know is on the minds of many people this
morning
we need to decide as a nation how much
power the government should have over
our data this is an issue that impacts
all of us and we will not shrink from
this responsibility today we're
welcoming a new member to the iPhone
family as you may have heard we're
calling it the iPhone se but we've made
some beautiful refinements including
this gorgeous rose gold finish our
amazing Apple a9 chip but the iPhone se
has the same processing performance as
the iPhone 6s the iPhone se delivers
incredible battery improvements we've
given it our incredible 12 megapixel
iSight camera what that means is you
want to take a selfie in low-light so
you get a picture like this instead of a
dark selfie it can even capture 4k video
we've added an incredible array of
advanced technologies the iPhone se
there's a really compact design which
makes it the most powerful 4-inch phone
ever we're going to start the price of
the iPhone se at only $399 the Apple
watch has become the top-selling
SmartWatch in the world today we're
introducing some brand new colors our
new woven nylon band there's new sport
and leather bands in all new colors and
there's a stunning space black Melanie's
Lou beginning today Apple watch will
start at just $2.99 that's our update on
Apple watch now I'd like to talk about
Apple TV now you can organize your apps
on your home screen a great update for
Apple TV with folders and expanded use
of both Siri and dictation next up is
iPad the second member of the iPad pro
family and it weighs less than 1 pound
there are so many new features and
innovations packed into the iPad pro it
is the ultimate PC replacement for all
those old PCs in the world and for the
first time ever in iOS device is a
configuration now with 256 gigabyte of
storage